shortly after surprising our teacher of
the year first lady uh
bill jill biden she stopped at umc to
thank health care workers for national
nurses week joe mohler was there and he
is live with the special visit joe
we know what a tough year it has been
for health care workers first lady jill
biden stopped by umc here to shed the
light on our nurses
biden arrived just before seven this
morning to greet and take pictures with
nurses and a number of other healthcare
workers
now this kicks off national nurses week
i could see many healthcare workers
tearing up over the special visit
i also spoke to amy runge a managing
nurse at umc
she says after a long year it's nice to
be appreciated
especially by the first lady
i think this year in particular i've
been a nurse for 24 years
and obviously this week and nurses day
means a lot to me
but this year in particular it it's
important it's been tough it's been
tough for all of us not just nurses
and it was a moment to just stop and say
well we can see
the light at the end of the tunnel
now check these out the first lady
handed out something special
white house-shaped sugar cookies that
were made at the white house some nurses
say they don't even know if they will be
eating it
because they might just want to freeze
it and keep it now the first lady
arrived here in las vegas
last night she stayed at the waldorf
astoria on the las vegas
strip from here she was headed to
colorado to meet with military spouses
reporting at umc joe mohler 8 news now